Old people. Why is everyone old all of a sudden? That's right. I'm sure everyone's seen this already.
*tehe*
*glug glug glug glug glug*
Old PewDiePie, why does PewDiePie look old? It's the FaceApp, they're back at it again. I wanted to actually try it out.
Let's try out a beautiful photo of myself.
It's so awkward.
Gorgeous. I feel like I'm the only one that bought this app. Maybe this will be interesting. Okay. Here we go. Okay. I'm so excited.
First, okay, wait, you can do so much, because I have the full version so I can see full beard. How does that look like?
Okay, five thousand likes and I'll grow back my beard. There you go. There it is. You know what?
Let's just start what people want to see people want to see the age one. How does Pewdiepie look when he's old?
Here we go. I'm at... ooh God, haha.
The thing is: the Kjellbergs, my family
we don't get gray hair, at least not my dad or I never saw my granddad with gray hair either l.
Luckily I'll get to keep my right blonde hair, but my god, it doesn't look good. Does it? Oh, let's add makeup.
Maybe that will save it. Yeah.
Can I save this? I'll just save it like that. Okay what happens if I take this one and then I turn myself.
Instead of old. I'll turn myself young. Oh my god. I look like James Charles.
Kill it, please... Double old? Oh god. Oh.
God can I do it again? How many times can you oldify yourself? *sings* One more time. That looks pretty good.
Hey guys, hey bros, it's me, PewDiePie. Welcome to Minecraft episode 50 hundred thousand million.
When I said Minecraft forever series, I meant it bros.
Female. Okay. Turn me into a chick, baby. Oh, heck. Yeah. Oh
Grandma Pewdiepie is looking hella, se-... fricksy.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, okay. Alright. Let's just do another photo. We'll do a blank face.
Smile is always so creepy to me cause it's just the teeth and nothing else.
What do you guys think?
Okay, they have upset as well.
What what happens if you take smile and add smile? Does it just double smile?
Triple smile it is. Smile for the camera, please. Here we go. Okay.
How does it work, I don't get it.
Gender swap here we go. Oh my god.
I look like my mom when she was younger. This is so creeping me out, dude. Why do I have a beard?
What's that? Oh, this? This is my new merch with Sven. Check it out.
We also have hairstyles. I'm always thinking what kind of hair I should get. Hey look, I'm Justin Bieber.
How do I look bald then? I mean I'll take it.
Let's do bald and then add a beard cause that's that's the look I truly want.
Luckily, my family, we all get to keep our hair. Maybe I'm an exception.
But you know if it does it's not that bad. Okay, let's try this with some other people. Okay, let's do Marzia.
Marzia, I'm sorry.
Old... well.
It's not bad. It's a lot better than me. That's for sure.
My God, science was not created for this. I keep telling you. What if we make her young again? Oh my God.
Oh my God, that's pretty good.
Damn, I mean she looked worse but...
Here's what I really want to see. Marzia as a dude.
No, no, I'll take this guy over...
How do I look like with a beard maybe, maybe that will make it better? Okay. Yeah, that's better.
Let's see if we can salvage this
Give him a smile.
With the right filters anyone can look good.
Just look at Trisha Paytas, everyone. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's starting to look better, change the hair color. We'll give myself a blonde.
We're gonna fix this, it's gonna be okay. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. I like that, maybe glasses to cover up some of those wrinkles.
No makeup necessary.
Hello, my name is PewDiePie and age is just a number.
Jesus Christ. All right, let's look at my man, Jack.
First of all, is he frickable as a female- the real question?
I mean, absolutely not. Is he frickable as old? Oh absolutely!
Is he frickable as... no, wait.
What? He looks like Zayn.
We all know him, but what about Mrs. Beast?
*laughs* Oh ho ho, look at this dude. *laughs*
What about grandpa Beast?
*laughs* Look at this dude.
What about beardy Beast?
Not bad look. Something to consider. Mr. Beast?
Are my friends frickable? Let's have a look.
It's Morgz's mom!
Damn, no difference.
What if we take Ken, female Ken, and turn into...
Back to male?
Oooh.
Ooh, that's weird. Oh God. It's so weird.
It looks so real but so fake at the same time, like it makes no sense. Alright, I gotta try Brad.
Brad has been posting a lot... a concernable amount of selfies lately. Brad, are you looking for a new girlfriend?
What is happening? Okay
Here we are. Brad's looking good, by the way, very nice. But how does he look like when he's old?
Why is it funny every time?
The same thing.
Wrinkles and gray hair, ha ha. What about Brad young?
Damn, it looks like Brad is making videos again. Oh wait, he is, check him out boy, shout out.
But is he frickable?
I don't think so.
Brad looks like...
Female Brad looks like he...
He's about to tell me why that word is insensitive.
Brad looks like he kind of person that will tap you on your shoulder in a pub and be like
"Can you guys keep it down? I'm trying to discuss books with myself"
Oh, that's right. I wanted to try if you can do it on Edgar.
What? And it shows a cat... They knew...
All right, let's nuke this thing.
Oh my God.
Hey guys, we're gonna bring back Happy Wheels. For the hundredth time, we're bringing back Happy Wheels!
It's gonna be epic, bros. At a quadrillion likes... Oh my God.
At a quadrillion likes.
Hey, let's just do one more. Just one more what could possibly ...? Where have my lips gone?
Why is my eyes sinking into themselves? Now, can these be salvageable?
That is the question. Young. Make me young.
What is this? Who is that? Who are you?
Wow, yeah, that looks good.
Ok, let's save that and let's make it young again. Oh, wow. That looks so good.
Wow!
I think... I think... I think it's ruined.
Well, maybe actually if we maybe turn into female it might correct itself. We're gonna blow up their servers now, there's too much...
Too much... oh!
Ooh la la, hahahaha!
I don't even know what I'm doing anymore.
Hey, also, we have 30% off now if you entered the code "pewdiepie".
If you want to check out and buy the
shaker and my favorite flavors check out a link in description, enter code "pewdiepie".
30% off, that's pretty epic.
Why don't you do like a really bad photo? It really looks like my old beard too - that's so freaky.
How do I look like with blond hair?
Not good. Not good, everyone. Okay, cool. How about black? I always wondered. Not good.
Okay, actually, you know what? I want to try and make myself
Find like, my, the best style. Maybe like a little bit more beard? Yeah. Yeah, that looks good.
We'll tin up the hair, just a little bit, just a little bit. I mean, it looks bad.
I don't know why I did it. Okay. It's just to change something. Hair style?
"How's it going, bros? It's 2014 Pewdiepie." How do I look like with long hair?
Oooh nooo! Oh my God!
Yes!
Long hair it is!
Okay, just give me the makeup. We want something subtle and classy. I want James Charles to approve.
Yeah, this is not what I'm looking for. Okay, matte, maybe. Oh my gosh.
And then...
Finally, just a little touch of youngness, little fountain of beauty
Let's get real, you'd let this creature call you daddy. Don't lie to me.
Oh my god, how can I forget. I have to...
What should I do? Female. But it's already female this makes no sense.
Oh my God!
Is it weird that he looks better without the filter? Let's fix the smile.
Oh yeah, a little fountain of youth.
I'm trying to make you better Brad, I'm sorry
I'm curious like what happens if you take an actual baby and make the baby old. Does that work?
Okay, what happened?
Wait, what's that movie Benjamin Button? All right
That's me playing around with FaceApp. I hope you had fun with me. It was, it was fun for me, Minecraft tomorrow. I promise.
Smash like if you enjoyed, subscribe. We're almost at a hundred million subscribers and at a hundred million something epic will happen.
Check out merch, very epic and thanks for watching. Bye bye.
WHAT? You never played Tuber Simulator?
PPFFSSHTT.
You know it's fun, right?
I'm not supposed to give my opinion but give it a try and then you can tell me if it's good or not.
Not convinced yet? Okay, I'll cut you a deal. The game is available for free and that's a great price!